[Music]
well a politician's job is to appeal to
voters left-leaning voters don't like
the NRA Pat Davis is a Democrat running
for Congress in New Mexico put two and
two together and Davis has produced a
new ad where he expresses his view of
the NRA unambiguously but you decide
the NRA their pro-gun policies have
resulted in dead children dead mothers
and dead fathers
I'm Pat Davis and I approve this message
because if Congress won't change our gun
laws we're changing Congress Pat Davis
joins us today for New Mexico Pat thanks
for coming on
hi Tucker so that that's the ad F the
NRA kind of moronic now that's that's it
just 15 seconds but it got a whole lot
of attention and start a new
conversation about guns and I'm grateful
for that but doesn't it degrade you I
mean you use the f-word in an ad I mean
if you have a position state it but F
the NRA I mean come on but well Tucker I
mean look being polite it hasn't made
our schools any safer it hasn't
protected police officers like I used to
be you know if an if a cuss word on TV
offends you more than pictures of dead
children and parkland or Newtown then
your priorities are all wrong I was a
cop for nine wait hold on wait let me
ask you question it's a it's not an
either/or and there's not that I'm so
offended
I just politeness doesn't work do you
think rudeness well as ruzhin rudeness
gonna save lives do you think well you
know as we were looking to make this ad
what we we kept coming up with the same
idea and every ad idea we came up with
to talk about this issue looked like
somebody else's and those had not worked
clearly this got the NRA s attention and
it has started a new conversation both
amongst candidates running for office
about who we can how we organize and
take back Congress and put new leaders
there to take on gun control but also
how we stand up to the NRA I mean we
know what works fifty percent of NR a
members a conversation about how
embarrassing you are I mean how many NRA
members have committed mass shootings
well but Tucker here's the thing a
majority of America is eighty nine
percent of police officers a majority of
here's the thing we can yeah you wait
you just released an ad this @fv NRA
which I'm sure back your fraternity
house they loved but let me ask you an
adult question how many NRA members have
committed mass shootings
this is about the organization itself my
family grew up when I was growing I'm
asking you about the organization sare
it's not the NRA than my dad's
organization it is how many of their
members are well they have millions of
members how many of them had I do that
week
look they remember I've been here living
the NRA made this their target we've
started a new conversation and what I've
also heard from our parents and with the
conversation Newtown who donated to keep
the act on the air because they want
people in Congress defines you're really
doing a public if the NRA regulations
that they're members trying to have an
adult conversation so here's your new
spot and I just I want to talk to policy
and see what you know about it so here's
your latest 15-second n by the time this
ad is done an ar-15 could have fired a
hundred and fifty points that's why we
need to ban assault weapons hi Pat Davis
running for Congress and I approve this
message because lives are more important
than gun company profits so you just
said that in 15 seconds an ar-15 can
fire a hundred and fifty rounds is it is
that right that's right well how much
right here in New Mexico you can go to a
you can go to a parking lot or go on the
internet buy an assault weapon an ar-15
and buy a legally available add-on that
like a bump stock that allows you to
replicate exactly what happened in Las
Vegas the Las Vegas are you saying
you're saying an ar-15 can shoot a
hundred and fifty rounds in 15 seconds
so would it have a hundred and fifty so
ground magazine what would that what
hold on let me ask you let's be specific
that you're at what would that magazine
look like the hundred and fifty run
magazine exactly like the magazines that
Las Vegas police officers pulled out of
the hotel room they had 50 and hundred
was capable oh no and you see you can
fire it is it is physically possible to
fight it's not I'm a decent rhetorical
questions you don't know what you're
talking about
and I know that you were a police
officer you claim to have been ya know
ar-15 can fire a hundred and fifty
rounds in 15 seconds that's untrue and
if you believe it is true and then
you're not qualified to have a
conversation about guns people are
laughing at you because you are in your
meeting but don't know what you're
talking about
no no exactly the word of the police
officers in Las Vegas who I trust who
ran into that room to save people down
below and found the weapons that
modified with bump stocks they they say
an ar-15 can what do you think what
happens to the barrel in 15 seconds if
you put a hundred and fifty rent it
would melt so I guess my point is a
check on the inner raters be mr. tough I
was a cop guy maybe you should know what
you're talking about but you don't
you're putting something on television
that's demonstrably wrong that's
physically impossible and all of your
voters like oh yeah this guy knows what
he's talking about he was a cop but she
don't know so maybe you should apologize
for it I'm not apologizing okay
I'm apologize for some actually I just
have not changed the conversation we
need a real conversation going here but
you don't know what you're talking about
so maybe you shouldn't be in a position
to make decisions because you don't
understand the issue because you just
told me with a straight face that an air
15 you can fire 150 rounds in 15 seconds
who's surprised it can't
so maybe you should admit that and move
on to something you understand would you
do that Tucker we're gonna go we're not
this is exactly the type of arguments
that don't get us where we need to be we
need new we need this didn't work tough
guy we politeness is not working so far
if you're if you woke up a hallway
saying don't hide your kid and you don't
work actually max werster's why don't
you get some facts Oh Pat do you like
this new mode of communication we have
if the owner iPad it'd be great that
tough guy
interview over yeah because you don't
know what you're talking about